[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
man don't don't put those hats back on
just yet please take them off for the
invocation it's wonderful to welcome you
here for this commencement ceremony
would you please bow your head and
prayer with me your word O Lord is a
lamp unto my feet and a light unto my
path heavenly father who has created us
and preserved us and generously bestowed
on us all the blessings of this life
draw our minds and our hearts to the
contemplation of your majesty
that we might desire nothing more than
you and might fear nothing more but the
loss of you and Carnot's son who has
become for us a high priest able to
sympathize with us in our weakness calm
our fears about the uncertainties of the
days ahead by the assurance of your
presence that we may enjoy that heavenly
peace which passes all earthly
understanding life-giving spirit who
sanctifies our lives and makes us living
sacrifice as well pleasing to God
receive our anticipation for the next
season ahead that the works of our hands
may be forever established in your sight
as a well pleasing aroma most totally an
ever Blessed Trinity and whose light we
see light and for whom our hearts are
restless until they rest in you use this
occasion of graduation from one season
of our lives to another to make us more
and more your very own that we may ever
walk in your sight unto our lives end
and at the last behold you face to face
and all this we ask through Jesus Christ
our Savior and our Lord who lives and
reigns for ever and ever
amen please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance
welcome hello seniors you ready yeah the
long past ready by now
welcome to the hundred and 67th
commencement exercises of Hillsdale
College I thank general Nellore and his
wife Darcy and his son our alum Brett
and his Bret's wife Kaylie for coming
here to join us today and I think the
general for his very great service to
our nation my job is to explained the
purpose of the ceremony
and to explain why we're all part of it
we've all produced it we've all made it
happen
we all must participate in it couldn't
happen without anybody here the purpose
of the college is not hard to state it's
just hard to do we're about to have our
hundred and seventy fifth year we're
going to start that and we're gonna
dedicate a beautiful Chapel and just as
Thomas is coming and everywhere around
the campus you see change which however
almost all looks like it isn't new and
that's because although the changes are
real and serious they're superficial
because the deeper thing is the same the
college was founded for four things the
next phase of our colleges history is
going to be called the four pillars
campaign and what are they they are the
elements of good living for human beings
they are freedom and faith and learning
and character if you read the 1844
document in beautiful language that's
what it says if you boil that down as we
have over the years it becomes known to
you in a way that helps guide how you
decide although as I say it's not always
easy to decide who are we here today
we divide into two groups the academic
community we're all wearing uniforms and
the rest of you whom we refer to behind
your backs as civilians as in be good
kids there are civilians here if you see
somebody walking across the campus you
don't know who they are it so it's a
good idea to go up and ask them who they
are because there's some visitor gawking
up at everything and you say welcome to
Hillsdale College the rest of us we take
each other for granted but not you
the most important group of you is the
parents I think what you've done now 21
years old grown up about to go onto the
world on their own and that thing you
started 21 years ago is coming to a peak
although I can tell you our children are
in their early 30s is not over the
parents here are parents weekend did you
find it to be a love fest I do we all
look forward to it poor faculty you know
they work hard and they have to stay up
you have to get up and say five hours on
Saturday morning talk to you all and
they always leave with a smile on their
face because it's a proof of the fact
that we're doing something together the
steering committee all of you parents
are members of the parents organization
steering committee and what four of them
couples of them are retiring this year
because their kids are graduating today
and we boot them out and I want to
mention their names and thank them and
all of you in the warmest words Michael
and Michelle Michael off Jeff and Alain
painter Tom and Barb Burrell and Tony
and Catherine Perry would you stand up
please
and would all of the parents stand up
please
it looks to me like each kid has four
parents another group of civilians it's
very important our a group we call
friends at the college friends is
anybody else who's not a parent and not
a member of the academic community and
likes to college the friends are
millions of people I mean it's not an
exaggeration it we have a mailing list
soon to reach five and a half million
and send them a publication every month
it's crazy and the great majority of
them don't give us any money we give
them easy chances to get off and they
must they don't what is it that they're
doing they come to events they take
online courses I'm always getting
stopped in airports now and somebody
walks up to me and says oh I'm taking
your online course and you know I have a
question and if you ask him how they do
on the exam they're just like freshmen
they look at their feet and shuffle
around we wouldn't be here except for
those people and I mean not lately
lately there's you know very many of
them I mean from the beginning the
college has always had friends enemies
too but the friends make it work and
there are many of you here today and
many more watching the stream of this
thing and I want to thank you warmly
did you see without you to the parents
and the friends no college no senior
class nothing here you're part of it
you've helped to make it happen
now we uniformed officers we divide it
into some groups those of us who have
stripes ma
sorry ba ma PhD oh yeah
that if you're the president of the
college you get a fourth stripe general
Miller has four stars it's just like
that isn't it and you know it just
divided into its units to and yet it's a
whole faculty of the most important
people who work here
I lied they have helped these young
people become equipped to live well as
adults and I can tell you because I love
to say it's hard work and it's a pain to
everyone involved
now the pains over two of them are
retiring dan Noke has been our librarian
since 1876 and he's the classic
librarian
he's uh he's calm
I've only seen him excited one time some
stupid boys let off some detergent bombs
that the where is he well the chemists
stand up van Armand Van Orman is our
next Provost Van Orman taught those boys
to make that bomb and so they go off in
the library and I get this email from
dead know called terrorist attack big
exclamation mark and then there's damage
in the library and I think you know
first I thought maybe it was a terrorist
attack and then you know about an hour
later emerges that it's four of our
students and so now I'm looking for them
and I know I'm gonna find them but and
you know they're just stupid they're not
bad I think one of them has a brother in
the senior class and but I won't call
out his name maybe and you know so I had
to Dean Pete and I were in a terrible
fix because I had to satisfy honor his
regards Dan note I needed to crucify
these boys but I do I didn't I just
talked to him really bad and then Dan
was happy
it'll be good without him because he's
laid the base but we won't forget that
he has laid it it is a modern library
and it never causes me a problem it's
I'm so grateful to him and the other one
the other retiring person is the founder
of our modern German department Everhart
Geyer he's an effective teacher he's one
of the kindest people I know he's a
sensitive man too and to know him is to
love him and he's leaving the department
in great hands it's bigger now annoys me
because it got better and then it got
bigger and then it cost the college more
money and I would like ever heart and
Dan note to stand up please and be
recognized
[Applause]
the Provost David Whelan has forever
been the Provost and he's retiring from
that job to do other jobs he's going to
go back to the English department mostly
but also he's agreed that he will do
everything I say for the rest of his
life that's literally true his actual
response was I'll let you retire I said
but you have to agree and he said of
course and Chris Van Orman the terrorist
supplier is going to become the Provost
but I would like us all to thank david
whele
[Applause]
we give awards for excellence in
teaching and the two chief ones ones
called the Doherty award and the others
the professor of the year the Doherty
award is given each year to in the
spring to a junior and in the fall to us
sorry you've got it backwards in the
fall to a junior in the spring to a
senior faculty member and if you ever
come to convocation you should come to
convocation it's the funnest thing and
next year it's going to be in our new
chapel and if you ever come you'll see
this award given and you can look at the
list of the names in the back and you
will see that they're among the greatest
teachers are alive everybody respects
them this year the winners are mark
cutoff and David Gabler in history and
math would they stand up please
[Applause]
Mark's got a boy graduating today you'll
be able to tell who it is he's like
really tall the professor of the year is
picked through a careful process we've
elaborated the process to make sure it's
deliberate they think about it they talk
about it and the senior class those guys
right there they picked the professor of
the year and it's a very high honor and
people who win it remember it forever
many here have won it
this year's professor of the year is the
chemistry professor Lee Ann Barron when
she stand up please
okay
you know to be unable to find Leanne
barren like if you were if you ever walk
across the campus and she's talking it
looks like she's doing simmer for and
she's not several people out the faculty
are the senior members of our academic
community and they guide it and they do
that collectively especially through the
operation of the core curriculum and I
have come to rely on them completely
please stand up faculty and let us thank
them
[Applause]
the junior members of our academic
community are the students the seniors
today are going to become full members
no longer novices they have on their
uniform the sign of their rank they love
to decorate their uniform by the way
with stuff and I hope they have it
because we don't like it because it's a
uniform and we can probably figure out
what that name means it's a sign of rank
you are to be marked an educated person
through a difficult curriculum that you
chose knowing it was harder than most
and you have come here and you have
thrived and excelled and we are grateful
to you it's kind of a weird class last
year Ryan Murphy a junior was doing the
internship program in Washington and she
led the advance team when when Mike
Pence came here so she led a vice
presidential advance team to her own
college and somebody told me that was
happening because she'd heard it from
the White House and I said is that a
good idea turned out fine they come over
to our house for dinner and there's you
know as you can see there's a lot of
them almost all of them come and they
make toast and they sing and carry on
and inspire and that's fun and you guys
were particularly fun this year I should
thank my wife because she organizes all
that and that's my wife penny could
stand up please
[Applause]
the word around here is there's plenty
of opinions about the president but
everybody likes his wife
the foolish taken James said to me
supported by the foolish Haley McGee
we're afraid the standards are getting
too high and we couldn't get in here and
I said gosh we'd be incompetent we
wouldn't figure out you guys could come
in so probably you'll still be able to
and your kids will too
Tovah foreman dominated the challenging
Sibelius concerto last night on the
violin and then she came over to my
house for the third time to play the
also difficult hot canary Joshua Brown
is another concern concerto winner with
the orchestra the whole Orchestra sorry
the chamber choirs so Holloman every
couple years Holloman comes and says the
Chamber Choir wants to go on a junket
and so we have junkets all over the
place we have events all over the
country and so we try to take them you
know but it's kind of expensive and
anyway they're super busy and the only
one we had that was near in any way was
an Indianapolis and it was on the
reading day before finals start and I
said to him they don't want to go on
there do they and they did oh you write
idiots and and so they come and they
sing and they sing their hearts out and
the early you're gonna hear them you
they really can't sing and it's a
beautiful thing and and the people who
come to our events they just love it
when they're there and on the other hand
they're all studying you know until two
in the morning driving back with their
books on their laps in the bus that's
what the seniors are like Trey Brock
it's gonna be a wide receiver for the
Kansas City Chiefs
lots of achievement among them the most
annoying thing about them is this
there's not a top ten there's a top
eleven
because their ties and I would have
thought throw somebody out but no named
11 and their names are Nicole alt and
Katherine Baden are and marina bas
tlemen and Gil West and hope Jonker and
Katherine do headway and Ellen Friesen
and Rebecca Kaiser and danielle
Masonville and samuel roberts and
justice Jessica's countess would they
stand up please
and this year's class has avoided the
shame of last year's class that all ten
are not girls but mostly they are of
course
here's another strange and terrible
thing we have to salutatorians and they
each have a 3.9 eight grade point
average and that only qualifies for 2nd
and they are Nicole alt and hope Jonker
they should stand up again please
Nicole is the editor of the paper and
also the outstanding senior want woman
and Sammy Roberts who's not as smart as
Nicole he only has a 3.9 5 is the
outstanding senior man and would they
stand up please
Sammy seems like a nerdy little boy
talking about Catholicism all the time
but if he ever stands up to talk
he's just hilarious there's like some
demon inside there and Nicole has been a
surpassingly good editor of our college
newspaper and I think her and John
Miller who manages all that the senior
class officers become my buddies and
comrades in crime because we set up all
this and we deliberate together with
thee and they they deliberate with the
people who elected them the officer ship
about who should be the commencement
speaker there was a consensus choice
this year but it's always complicated
and you got to figure out who you're
gonna please and somebody will always
complain except I don't think anybody
this year you know who's against the
Marine Corps or rephrase it who's alive
who's against the Marine Corps so I'm
going to name them before mentioned Ryan
Kelly Murphy as the president and the
vice-president is Marcus capper ski whom
I advise when he's getting a standing
ovation after a concert he should smile
because I've never seen him not smiling
in any other context the Secretary is
Kathleen Russo the treasurer is Kerry
Williams the social chair is faith with
Kowski and the fundraising chairs
Andy Chandler and the fundraising
co-chair see he got D'Amato they're
co-chairs nick de clean with those
officers to end up please
I you guys are really good yesterday
this senior class made me cry and that's
good you know I do sentimental things
all the time and I become callous and
don't care anymore but we were in the
chapel and it is I promise you you
should come back in the fall it's an
inspiring place and Hollywood will tell
you it sounds great when they sing in it
and all and I was telling the story
about how you see God and the
culminating point was you could see the
God if you're looking up in the chapel
but of course you can see God in their
relationships you can see them when they
talk into the night when they inspire
each other and teach each other which is
mostly what happens here because you
know they go and talk to these old
people over here who know infinite
amount and who are mature in their
academic talents which are very great
and then they go and they work with each
other to figure out what it means and
they come to love each other
another way in which the college is like
the Marine Corps very like it the
general and I've been noticing that all
day today and when I said that about six
of them burst into tears and that's what
made me cry they love each other they
should
stand-up seniors
[Applause]
thank you where's Trey Brock could you
be bothered to come here Trey Brock
stand up Trey Brock oh there what are
you doing over there okay he's gonna
play in the NFL I don't know if you'll
be any good
[Applause]
no from us seniors that you're a special
bunch of people and we're gonna miss you
but this is still home you join the
academic community you're in it for life
the responsibilities that go with it
because think what everybody has done
here by everybody in this opportunity
and in this auditorium represents
millions more who are invested in your
education and you are invested in each
other and they are invested in you and
in each other and it's foolish to
undertake something like this it'd be
like joining the marine car corps and
not trying to be brave coming here and
not trying to be good and wise and true
that'd be a mistake and I know you're
not gonna make that mistake and that's
why we love you Robert be Nellore is the
37th Commandant of the United States
Marine Corps he's a native of East
Lansing Michigan he has degrees from the
University of Virginia and Pepperdine he
joined the Marines in 1975 since then
he's been to the army officer Advanced
Course you'd think he would go to the
Advanced Course being the Commandant of
the Marine Corps the Marine Corps
command and Staff College the NATO
Defense College and the armed forces
Staff College
he's been the commander of Marine Forces
Command from in 2014 and 15 Central
Command 2012 to 2014 marine security
force company Panama during Operation
Just Cause that's when we went down
there and creamed Noriega he was in our
operation
Iraqi Freedom is the deputy commanding
general he was director of operations
for the Joint Staff in Washington DC
he's been president of the Marine Corps
University I didn't know that until
today he and his wife Darcy have three
children one of them Brett a graduate of
our college and a football player I will
say about general Miller that I went to
barracks one with Mike Murray one time
to watch the Friday night drill which is
awesome all summer long in Washington
you should go
I bet Murray can get you a ticket and
because I'm a big cheese and because
Brett Miller went here I got invited to
the private reception and it was full of
Obama officials and I thought oh wow
yeah I guess they run the Marine Corps
too and a lot of dignitaries and the
general came out and gave a talk and he
introduced them all and I thought you
know I wonder well never mind you can
imagine what I wondered and then he said
at the end he said in you know the
president of the best college in America
is here tonight and he introduced me me
and I was stunned and then all of the
generals there it was like 60 stars on
shoulders came marching over to me to
shake my hand and asked me about
Hillsdale College general Bailey has
been here since then and so what does
that mean that means this is a man who
says what he thinks and he has been very
brave hasn't he please welcome Robert
Nellore
thank you
I don't I don't give speeches so I'm
gonna ask permission from dr. armed to
walk around and talk to you a little bit
but - he and mr. Sajak new chairman of
the board I did I did consider the offer
you made me dr. Arnn because he thinks
so much of you seniors that he said just
take them all and enlist him in the
Marine Corps and I said yes no I'm just
kidding I had you for a second though
dinner for me this is probably not a
normal thing yesterday and today I was
presiding in in a giving an oath of
office commissioning about 35 officers
in the United States Navy and the United
States Marine Corps
yesterday at College Station Texas A&M
and today here at Hillsdale and I'll be
very frank to the to the seniors here
speaking to this to this audience I'm a
little bit nervous and the reality is
you're probably not going to remember a
single thing I say so I will try to
endeavour to break that likelihood but
as I thought about it you know given a
doing a commissioning and talking to
those that are going to follow a path
that I've followed for the past 40 years
is something you would expect me to be
able to do the life that that I chose
actually 44 years ago almost to a day
commissioned a second lieutenant was not
my plan my plan was to do my three years
and then go out and find my fortune
elsewhere and then over time this didn't
became what I did it became what I am
and I think I speak the same for the
faculty if you become a teacher or
eventually teaching is not what you do
it's what you are
but as I started to think about it I
realized as I was going through the
process and am and here today and
watching it and looking at the faces of
the the
we were commissioning this really is not
a whole lot different than a
commissioning and let me tell you why I
feel that way
those those officers now officers were
students and like you they're beginning
the next path and in their life they've
completed the rigors of an academic
institution you're going to be awarded a
degree and with that degree becomes
becomes responsibilities and at those
same events the one thing I also noticed
is the parents so I believe that the
great majority you hopefully are blessed
by having somebody here to thank you
afterwards and you're gonna get your
degree and they're gonna come down and
and they're gonna look at you and
they're gonna hug you and say I'm so
proud of you and you're gonna feel good
about that and you should feel good
about that I don't want you to ever
forget how that feels to have that pride
of your parents or grandparents your
friends your brothers your sisters
whomever congratulate you on this day
but that's just a first step and I guess
I would ask the seniors we recognize the
parents I'd ask you to join me in a
round of applause for your parents and
your family they're here to support you
today
[Applause]
now your job is to go out and get a job
with health insurance so what am I going
to say to you that would be different
than what I would say to a group of
young men and women that are putting on
the uniform to defend their nation and
take on the demands of that profession I
don't really think it's any different
and I don't think it's any different
than what you've heard here while you've
been a student at Hillsdale I think the
qualities and the attributes that make
people successful I think if you talk to
mr. Sajak or all the other people that
are here the van handles or all the
people in business and the very
successful people who rightfully and
properly support this universe of this
college there's no rocket science here
so in the Marine Corps they they tell
you to keep it in threes because people
can remember three things so let me give
you three thoughts effort matters you
wouldn't be sitting here today getting
ready to come across this podium to
receive a degree if you were not exert
if you are not able to exert effort but
that effort doesn't end today in fact
the demands of your effort are going to
be even greater there's a huge amount of
talent among you your talent is only
going to result in achievement if you're
willing to put in the effort and so thus
far you have and I know you'll continue
to do that but the demands on your
effort as you compete against people
outside this college and around the
world are going to require more effort
the United States is in a competition
around the world with others it will
take our effort to come out on top
the second thing there will be adversity
there may have already been adversity in
your life your parents will probably
could tell you about adversity may was
adversity that they've dealt with
somebody but there will be times in the
future when things won't go well it may
be professionally it may be personally
there will be days when you'll be
challenged
but your measure as a man or woman a
virtue and character is going to be
graded on or evaluator and how you
persevere you can't quit
you can't quit I mean the Marine Corps
teaches us that you can't quit you
figure out you adapt you overcome you
persevere you figure out a way to solve
the problem and you've got all these
people that dr. Arnn talked about
friends of the college your parents or
friends your family your fellow
classmates who are going to be there to
help you figure it out you're never
alone you're never alone so we have to
overcome we have to persevere and the
third thing is character counts
character counts and that's what this
college is really all about this college
is all about character I mean you're
smart you you're academically qualified
but I think the thing that may give you
an edge is that discussions you've had
about what's right what's wrong what's
honor
what's integrity what's virtue what is a
good man or woman speaking well what is
accountability and responsibility
so all those character traits you think
about the person in your life they may
be sitting in this room with us they may
be in the faculty here they may be
friends they put they're probably family
members coaches teachers people that
admire that you admire that inspired you
over the years to get you to this point
today and they had all those qualities
qualities they worked hard they exerted
effort they were men and women of virtue
and character they were humble they were
respectful they did everything to make
everybody else better it was never about
them it was always about the team so
character counts so that's my message
effort matters character counts and we
have to persevere in all things that we
do in closing again I appreciate the
opportunity to be here with you today
and I congratulate you all on your
achievement and I CRO grad
your families for their support because
at the end of the day when it's all said
and done they're gonna say something
about us and the first part of that
sentence has already been written it's
going to say your name your hometown and
it's going to say Hillsdale graduate and
then there's a space there's a space and
somebody's going to write something in
that space and that you own that space
so what do you want it to say this
College has given you the foundation to
fill that space in the right and proper
way and I know you're going to take
advantage of that so make it count
make it count I'm very proud to be here
with you today again to the families
thank you for your support for your your
graduate I know they are going to need
your help in the future and I know
you'll be there for them
and for all of you that are graduating
best of luck and I wish you all well in
whatever endeavor you take on in the
future thank you very much
[Applause]
I just told the general that's one of
the best commencement speeches I ever
heard thank him very much would you come
forward general please
if you look in that area right there on
his left decorating this main is
redundant
upon the recommendation of the Faculty
of Hillsdale College and with the
authority vested in me by its Board of
Trustees I confer upon general Robert
Dean Nellore the honorary degree Doctor
of public service
I skipped over something and I think the
psychology department will tell me
because they tell me that it's because
I'm repelled by this something we have
three valedictorians and they all have
four points what is the world comin to
and the one I know the best he's not
even that smart they actually are all
three of them awesome
it's it's curious that they're three
I've never seen that before
I've never seen most years there's no
four point this time three and then more
amazing still one of them is a boy and
their names are Kathryn Baden R and
marina bas Coleman and Gil West please
stand up
Catherines going to medical school and
Marina's going to graduate school and
Gil West is going to go into the Marine
Corps when he can do enough pull-ups so
now we know he's going to be able to do
them because I've called him out we're
giving honorary degrees today to three
people who are not here they are mr.
Robert Bruce and mr. and mrs. David and
Margaret brownie it's interesting why
they're not here Robert Bruce is in the
financial industry started a mutual fund
mr. and mrs. grown II started the
independence tub corporation a steel
company these three people are friends
to the college which means something
more than that they are generous to it
although they very much are they love it
they love it for the same reason we all
love it they're not here today because
they do not want any fuss made or any
notice given they do not want anything
at all from us except for us to do our
work see the obligations we all have
they wouldn't they wouldn't come it's a
judgment that I won't alienate them
completely by praising them in front of
all of you and whoever is watching on TV
but I'm doing it anyway let them stand
for the millions of people who are like
them who wish us well and love the
things that we love so please give them
a round of applause
Steven Van Andel is a alum of Hillsdale
College he graduated in when - when 1991
1951
he's a a polo champion he won the US
Open and polo in that strange we told
him there was a board resolution because
he lost it in the finals a couple times
if he didn't win it we were going to ask
him to leave the board so he did he took
over the amway corporation from his
father and from his father's friend and
partner dick DeVos and with his partner
dick DeVos he multiplied its size and it
was already huge
he's been twice chairman of the US
Chamber of Commerce
he's been chairman of many business
councils he's on the board of directors
at the Gerald r Ford Presidential
Foundation yesterday he became the vice
chairman of our board he's one of the
nicest people I know also
steady judgment then he married Amy Amy
was born and raised in West Michigan
she's been a nurse for 30 years she does
the hard kind of Nursing when people are
really sick and dying she's taking care
of people whose families remember her
and always will she's bossy
if she weren't so kind I said never
earlier
she's such a force of nature that she
would wreak terrible destruction
thank God then that she's so kind and it
is a matter of particular pride to me to
be able to present them honorary degrees
please come forward
upon the recommendation of the Faculty
of Hillsdale College and with the
authority vested in me by its Board of
Trustees I confer upon Steve and Amy Van
Andel the honorary degree Doctor of
public service
[Applause]
you see mark Colt off would make a
better Provost
under the direction of James Holloman
the Hillsdale College Chamber Choir
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
wonderful Jim the general thinks you're
really good
Brian Kelley Murphy is well known here
as the elder sister of Taryn Murphy
Taryn just won the Everett contest which
Ryan also had earlier one and so between
them I think they've scooped up six
grand from the college and I'm pleased
to announce that ryan has pledged that
back to the college
he's majored in politics he's from
Temecula California I have a list of the
organizations that she's which she's a
member and it's a list of all the
organizations Kappa Kappa Americans Pi
Sigma Alpha on and on and on she won the
oratory contest she's a stunning young
woman she's full of goodness and
positive outlook and intelligence and
achievement I can't stop her she is the
senior class president
she's soon to start her own scarf
business which she's calling blessing
Sunday whatever that means Ryan Murphy
I was bored mom was at Bible study dad
was watching Monday Night Football and I
was a seven year old with a lot of time
on her hands so I did what any young kid
would do I attempted to make marmalade
from scratch I didn't have a recipe I
had never made marmalade before let
alone tasted it probably I just knew
there were a bunch of orange trees
outside and I wanted to experiment as
Hank Williams jr. belted out are you
ready for some football dad kept a
watchful and curious eye while I piloted
a burning stove and a whole jamb
operation then mom got home after
recovering from the initial shock that
her seven-year-old daughter was stirring
a boiling cauldron of caramelized orange
pulp mom gave the marmalade a taste much
to her surprise it was good so good that
she encouraged me to start a marmalade
business but before I could sell it to
all of my grandma's friends I needed one
very important thing
jars seeking out the perfect jars I
found them they were sturdy beautiful
and unusually shaped square with rounded
edges and I loved them those little jars
are what I think of when we're calling
my days as a little marmalade
entrepreneur nothing gave me more joy
than to fill those jars to the very top
and pass them on for someone to enjoy
those vessels made the difference I
filled them up so they could be poured
out in ancient times jars held water
wine food scrolls treasure they held
at times their purpose seemed more
glamorous other times less so but they
were all vessels used toward a purpose
greater than themselves they were filled
so they could be poured out in 2nd
Corinthians 4 the Apostle Paul alludes
to people being like jars of clay ready
to carry and pour out the truth of
Christ's redemptive love for us God is
the master potter and we're the clay
molded and ready to fulfill his plan for
our lives and for his greater glory
Paul writes God has made his light shine
in our hearts to give us the light of
the knowledge of God's glory
displayed in the face of Christ but we
have this treasure in Jars of Clay to
show that this all surpassing power is
from God and not from us you and I the
class of 2019 are those jars over the
past four years we've been formed molded
pulled stretched and shaped constantly a
work in progress
we have been poured into with the
intended purpose that after today we
will pour into others what we've gleaned
from this place we've trusted for years
of our lives to this college at this
point close to 20 percent of our 22
years alive we trusted the people here
to invest in us hold us up and take us
along dr. Barron parade with us before
chemistry exams dr. Carrington helped us
navigate the political magnitude of the
American Founding dr. Blackstock
imparted thoughtful words of wisdom
lessons and ethics to carry into the
business world and dr. Arnn kept us on
her toes with
ever hover in question what is the good
each of us can think of a time probably
many in which our professors have
invested in us intellectually and
spiritually our friends to have
sharpened and built us up and poured
into us we trust these 1080 days as
Hillsdale College students have prepared
us for a task greater than ourselves
seeking spreading and preserving truth
and while it may seem like we're each
taking different roads after graduation
after the caps come off the cars packed
up with our belongings and we leave this
place for the last time as students
we're really not on different paths at
all we are each stewards of what we now
hold talents skills character and
knowledge of what is beautiful and good
it is our duty to use these for God's
glory we are filled to the brim but
there is danger now of squandering this
treasure entrusted to us what good is it
if it stays bottled up
what good are hidden talents what good
is a light hidden under a bushel as jars
of clay the focus should not be on us
the world is thirsting for knowledge for
hope for truth you have it not by your
power but by God's giving us grace and
understanding we are called now to pour
it out in service of others and in
service to Christ
I don't know what that girl's gonna do
for a living but we're all going to know
about it for sure well the candidates
for doctoral degrees please stand and
remain standing
they're already standing
who told you guys to come over there and
master's degrees you over there too yeah
yeah they don't know when to line up
well the graduating class of 2019 please
stand up upon the recommendation of the
Faculty of Hillsdale College and with
the authority invested in me by its
Board of Trustees I confer upon each of
you the degree for which you've been a
candidate and Mitch you admit you to all
the rights privileges and
responsibilities to which you are
entitled and obliged congratulations
dr. Street oh please proceed with the
graduate degrees will the doctor will
the Doctor of Philosophy graduates and
politics please come forward
Veronica lighter Brooks
Alisa born Horst Cortez Peter Richard
Watson cross
[Applause]
Thomas James Tacoma
[Applause]
congratulations to our doctoral
graduates
will the Master of Arts graduates and
politics please come forward
Victoria Noel Antrim
Joey Michael beretta
[Applause]
Michael Joseph Driscoll
Matthew Robert Hazelton
[Applause]
[Music]
Clayton John Rinku
[Applause]
Michael Merton
[Applause]
Paul Sebastian
mitr Mayer Laura Emily Marcos
Christopher O'Keefe
[Applause]
Christina Lee skirt William Wesley
terton the third Brett Charles wait
[Applause]
congratulations to our masters graduates
on behalf of the Graduate faculty I'd
like to say what a pleasure it has been
to work with these students some of them
over the course of many years we expect
great things and we wish them Godspeed
dr. R and the awarding of graduate
degrees is complete
[Applause]
professor cult off please proceed with
the undergraduate degrees well the
graduates of accounting please come
forward
David
Preston Van note the second Bachelor of
Science and accounting
honors in accounting John Henry hit
Bachelor of Arts in accounting
departmental honors in accounting Jared
Francis schipper Bachelor of Arts
accounting Adan Donovan Bachelor of Arts
in accounting [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in accounting Donald Steven ring
Bachelor of Arts in accounting
[Applause]
hung Noyan VIN Luang Bachelor of Arts
accounting Audrey Lee cook Bachelor of
Arts and accounting summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in accounting will
the graduates and American Studies come
forward
Kathleen and Russo Bachelor of Arts
American Studies magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in American Studies
Josephine Luna Vaughn Dolan Bachelor of
Arts American Studies
[Applause]
Joshua Simeon Pratt Co Bachelor of Arts
American Studies Combe Lauda and
departmental honors American Studies
Corrine L Proust Bachelor of Arts
American Studies Katelyn Faye mikowski
Bachelor of Arts American Studies [ __ ]
laude erin marie Grice Bachelor of Arts
American Studies and rhetoric and public
address magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in American Studies and in
rhetoric and public address
Brendan John OC Bachelor of Arts
American Studies Combe lauda
departmental honors in American Studies
[Applause]
with the graduates and applied
mathematics come forward that was quick
with the Batchelor with the Batchelor
candidates in art please come forward
Emily and Southgate Bachelor of Arts in
art and French summa [ __ ] laude
Madeline May Richards Bachelor of Arts
in art Zane
Paul Miller Bachelor of Arts in art leaf
Eric Andersen Bachelor of Arts in art
Samuel Eliot Galipeau Bachelor of Arts
in art Marley Therese Bush Matt Bachelor
of Arts in art and English with the
candidates in biochemistry come forward
Austin Michael Sandusky Bachelor of
Science in biochemistry [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Cara dawn violet el bachelor of science
and biochemistry [ __ ] laude stefanos
Yannick applause Bachelor of Science
biochemistry [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in biochemistry benjamin warren
Mayola Bachelor of Science biochemistry
Sheila Jessica Jane Taylor Bachelor of
Science biochemistry [ __ ] laude joshua
kenneth lay master Bachelor of Science
biochemistry
Tiffany Marie Farris Bachelor of Arts
biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
Mason pain clutter Bachelor of Science
biochemistry kaeleen G Bauer Bachelor of
Science in biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors biochemistry
rosemary Clare Payne's Bachelor of
Science biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors biochemistry
[Applause]
Nicholas Francis de clean Bachelor of
Science biochemistry
claire marie gwit Bachelor of Science
biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
Julia Margaret Bosco Bachelor of Science
and biochemistry
summa [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
biochemistry Nicholas Jon Faine Bachelor
of Science biochemistry Laurel Jordan
arms Bachelor of Science in biochemistry
and French summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in biochemistry Joshua Joseph
Brown Bachelor of Science and
biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
[Applause]
Christopher Isaac Huffman Bachelor of
Science biochemistry Nora grace Gibbs
Bachelor of Science biochemistry
magna [ __ ] laude natalie louise mekel
Bachelor of Arts and biochemistry magna
[ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
[Applause]
Katherine grace - had--we Bachelor of
Science biochemistry departmental honors
in biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Christine Annette Oh Sherman Bachelor of
Science biochemistry
magna [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
biochemistry Catherine Alexandra Bodnar
Bachelor of Science in biochemistry and
economics summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in biochemistry Christopher James
clinger Bachelor of Science in
biochemistry and politics magna [ __ ]
laude with the degree candidates in
biology please come forward Jacqueline
and Langer Bachelor of Science biology
Erin Lindsay Flaherty Bachelor of
Science biology magna [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Emily Alexis Holton Bachelor of Science
biology Elizabeth Catherine Palmer
Bachelor of Science in biology [ __ ] laude
sarah elizabeth de Lappe Bachelor of
Science biology
[Applause]
Monica Marie 2e Bachelor of Science
biology Genevieve Elizabeth Chiara
bachelor of science biology [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biology faith
nikoline wachowski bachelor of science
biology Lauren Whitney Schlitz
bachelor of science biology Caroline
Mary Andrews bachelor of science biology
magna [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
biology
Alise
janice Farley Bachelor of Science in
biology departmental honors in biology
magna [ __ ] laude marina
Noel BA Suleman bachelor of science
biology summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in biology onder's men well
Torres bachelor of science biology magna
[ __ ] laude
Andrew Michael Loman bachelor of science
biology [ __ ] laude Ryan Christopher
Lardner bachelor of science biology [ __ ]
laude daniel Udell Masonville bachelor
of science biology summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biology Brittany
Betty Leigh Bachelor of Arts biology he
sang lead bachelor of science biology
[ __ ] laude matthew Steven Moskowitz
bachelor of science biology Caitlin
Virginia Lowry Bachelor of Science in
biology
[ __ ] laude Daniel Allen Theory bachelor
of science biology and a wee no koro
bachelor of science biology benjamin
Wayne Evans bachelor of science biology
Rachel Lynn Tulsa Bachelor of Science in
biology summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in biology Elizabeth Catherine
Lewis bachelor of science biology summa
[ __ ] laude departmental honors in biology
Anakin jillian Ellingson bachelor of
science biology [ __ ] laude Wyatt
Connor bat Dorf bachelor of science
biology
Seth Cutler Johnson Bachelor of Science
biology Joseph Dominic spampinato
Bachelor of Science biology with the
candidates for degree in chemistry
please come forward
Jared Alexander goal Bachelor of Science
chemistry
magna [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
chemistry Charles Thomas Yoast Bachelor
of Science chemistry Nathan Jerome Pando
Bachelor of Science chemistry Anthony
Joseph distrito Bachelor of Arts in
chemistry and Latin magna [ __ ] laude
honors in chemistry and classics
Rebecca Carol Holscher Bachelor of
Science and chemistry
magna [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
chemistry Madeline Louise Gish Bachelor
of Science and chemistry magna [ __ ] laude
ryan joy Norton Bachelor of Science and
chemistry
[ __ ] laude Yee's a Bachelor of Science in
chemistry and mathematics with the
candidates and Christian Studies please
come forward
Carrie Lynette Olson Bachelor of Arts
Christian Studies Jeremy
Russell Hewitt Bachelor of Arts in
Christian Studies and Spanish with the
candidates and classics come forward
Jesse Alexander failed Bachelor of Arts
classics
Tovah Catherine Foreman Bachelor of Arts
classics [ __ ] laude
Suzanne Louise param Bachelor of Arts
Latin summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and classics mark garrison
Compton Bachelor of Arts classics and
philosophy magna [ __ ] laude Chloe grace
Riky Bachelor of Arts classics summa [ __ ]
laude Madeline Lily Albrecht
Bachelor of Arts in classics magna [ __ ]
laude Carrie and Bionic Bachelor of Arts
in classics magna [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
with the candidates and economics please
come forward
Teresa Lee patent Bachelor of Arts
economics magna [ __ ] laude ashley lane
Bachelor of Arts in economics and French
Thomas Barton Mullen Bachelor of Science
in economics Matthew Lawrence painter
Bachelor of Arts economics Michael
Powell / shitski
Bachelor of Science in applied
mathematics and economics Erin M hoot re
Bachelor of Science in applied
mathematics and economics
Alexander Nathaniel Taylor Bachelor of
Arts economics magna [ __ ] laude anna
elise Perry Bachelor of Arts economics
magna [ __ ] laude
Carly Regan Reno Bachelor of Arts in
economics and Spanish [ __ ] laude
Emma Pauline McCormack Bachelor of Arts
in economics [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in economics Nicole Renee alt
Bachelor of Arts in economics summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in economics
Rebecca Marie Kaiser Bachelor of Science
in economics summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in economics amber
suryya crump Bachelor of Arts in
economics [ __ ] laude
Jonathan Girard lap ssin Bachelor of
Arts in economics magna [ __ ] laude Dillon
rain Lawton Ville Bachelor of Arts in
economics [ __ ] laude elizabeth christine
Luke's Bachelor of Arts in economics
[Applause]
Andrew Arthur Berryhill Bachelor of Arts
in economics summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in economics
Peter Steven Ling Dahl Bachelor of Arts
in economics magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors economics John David
cornice Bachelor of Arts in economics
and mathematics summa [ __ ] laude
Gordon Matthew Bear Bachelor of Arts in
economics and politics all right Luke
Daniel Douglas barbarac Bachelor of Arts
in economics [ __ ] laude
Genevieve Rose sue hitta Bachelor of
Arts in economics [ __ ] laude
Tavia and this cows kiss bachelor of
science and economics and Spanish Coop's
summa [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Pierce Jonathan Pomerleau Bachelor of
Arts economics John Frederick Novak
Bachelor of Arts economics Colin
McDowell Baymen Bachelor of Arts in
economics magna [ __ ] laude
Jonathan Thomas Cal Katara Bachelor of
Science
economics Samuel Ross castles Bachelor
of Science applied mathematics and
economics [ __ ] laude departmental honors
and mathematics and departmental honors
in economics Michael Jonathan chasin
Bachelor of Arts in economics magna [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in economics
[Applause]
Marcos Samuel Cooper Ski Bachelor of
Arts in economics magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in economics Joseph
Marshall Siler Bachelor of Arts
economics Kerry Ann Williams Bachelor of
Science applied mathematics and
economics magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in economics
Catherine and Fassett Bachelor of Arts
economics Adam Ballantine Pierce
bachelor science economics and
psychology [ __ ] laude Jacob Thomas Bruce
our Bachelor of Arts economics Eric
Tyler Halverson Bachelor of Arts
economics [ __ ] laude departmental honors
in economics miles Lincoln Garn Bachelor
of Arts economics with the candidates in
English please come forward
John Wilson Roman Bachelor of Arts in
English [ __ ] laude thomas excuse me
Eric Thomas rig Bachelor of Arts in
English and theater summa [ __ ] laude
Austin James Benson Bachelor of Arts in
English and theater summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in English and
theater Dillon Jacob straily Bachelor of
Arts English Isabel
Helen Parral Bachelor of Arts in English
and religion Regan Nicole lash Bachelor
of Arts in classics and English magna
[ __ ] laude
Madalyn Murray berry Bachelor of Arts in
art and English magna [ __ ] laude Therese
Elaine Boyd Bachelor of Arts in English
magna [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
English Mary Grace Therese Alice
Bachelor of Arts in English magna [ __ ]
laude
[Applause]
Judith merino Bachelor of Arts in
English and theater [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in theater
Emily Ruth hider
Bachelor of Arts in art and English and
Virginia but sell Bachelor of Arts in
English summa [ __ ] laude Brian
Ronald cliff Bachelor of Arts in English
Jessica faith Scout Asst Bachelor of
Arts in English summa [ __ ] laude
Haley ray Halbrook Bachelor of Arts in
English summa [ __ ] laude
Natalie Katherine Taylor Bachelor of
Arts in English come louder
Lydia Christine Hall Bachelor of Arts
English Ryan Michael Byrnes Bachelor of
Arts English
Henry Sebastian Liston Berger Bachelor
of Arts English
Molly Catherine Andrews Bachelor of Arts
English summa [ __ ] laude grace and
Houghton Bachelor of Arts in English
Combe louder Madison a McAfee Bachelor
of Arts English Chloe
Murray kikuchi Bachelor of Arts English
summa [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
English Anna grace timís Bachelor of
Arts in English [ __ ] laude Julie
Josephine have luck Bachelor of Arts in
English [ __ ] laude
congratulations Brooke Johanna
Conrad Bachelor of Arts in English magna
[ __ ] laude
Cecelia Mariah platon Bachelor of Arts
in English
[Applause]
Hannah Marie sokolovsky Bachelor of Arts
in English summa [ __ ] laude emily
Virginia Walker Bachelor of Arts in
English magna [ __ ] laude alexander
Malcolm Stevenson green Bachelor of Arts
English with the candidates and Exercise
Science please come forward
Calvin Douglas Kinney bachelor science
and Exercise Science [ __ ] laude Allison
Elizabeth EADS Bachelor of Science
exercise science summa [ __ ] laude Julia
Carey Foreman teen Bachelor of Science
exercise science summa [ __ ] laude
Madeleine Julia Bessette Bachelor of
Science exercise science
Brittany Kristen gray Bachelor of
Science exercise science
Roberta hope Briggs Bachelor of Science
exercise science
Nicholas Francis GAD would Bachelor of
Science exercise science summa [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Caitlyn Marie Kish Bachelor of Science
exercise science Magna cume Lauda
departmental honors in sports studies
[Applause]
Levi Jacob wise Bachelor of Science
Exercise Science Christian Donald Rodino
Bachelor of Science Exercise Science
Magna cume Lauda departmental honors and
sports studies with the candidates for
degree in financial management come
forward Carter James Wilson Bachelor of
Arts financial management Brendan Eric
Rolfe Bachelor of Arts financial
management John Andrew Sarris a Bachelor
of Arts and economics and financial
management Justin Louis Hyman Bachelor
of Science Financial Management McKenna
Nicole OTT Bachelor of Arts Financial
Management
Allison Jones wire Bachelor of Arts
financial management and Spanish [ __ ]
laude departmental honors and management
Joseph Lee Hamrick Bachelor of Arts
financial management Kevin Dean Monson
Bachelor of Arts financial management
Jacob Paul de pillow Bachelor of Arts
financial management magna [ __ ] laude
Michael Patrick Mitchell Bachelor of
Arts Financial Management Nicholas Roy's
are now Ski Bachelor of Arts financial
management magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors Harrison Joseph Nico Bachelor of
Arts Financial Management Jonathan
Michael Wilkinson Bachelor of Science
financial management Andrew Joseph
shirred Bachelor of Arts financial
management [ __ ] laude
Joshua David Hoover Bachelor of Arts
financial management andreas William
Pfizer Bachelor of Arts Financial
Management James Michael McGrath
Bachelor of Arts Financial Management
hope Katherine Jonker Bachelor of Arts
financial management summa [ __ ] laude
amanda marie amara bachelor of science
financial management summa [ __ ] laude
william Kendricks Necker Bachelor of
Arts financial management [ __ ] laude
matthew john grunts fight bachelor of
arts financial management andrew Francis
Grayson Bachelor of Science applied
mathematics and financial management
Alexander Mark Harvey Bachelor of Arts
financial management
Nolan Scott Kundali Bachelor of Arts
financial management
Matthew Ray Johnson Bachelor of Arts
financial management Dana and Nicole
Newell Bachelor of Science Financial
Management Devon and Pogue Bachelor of
Science financial management magna [ __ ]
laude departmental honors and financial
management
[Applause]
Alec Lauren yo Bachelor of Arts
Financial Management Kevin
Robert Kirby Bachelor of Arts Financial
Management and Spanish with the
candidates in French please come forward
Jemima Ruth Soriano kaku's Bachelor of
Arts French [ __ ] laude
Morgan Jane Chanel's Bachelor of Arts
English and French [ __ ] laude Michaela
and Brisky Bachelor of Arts in English
and French [ __ ] laude Laura Jean Clavin
Bachelor of Arts French summa [ __ ] laude
with the candidates in German please
come forward
katarina Martin Bradford Bachelor of
Arts in German and philosophy [ __ ] laude
elizabeth grace demske Bachelor of Arts
German Elizabeth and loaves ASCII
Bachelor of Arts German summa [ __ ] laude
Lydia Helen Reyes Bachelor of Arts
German departmental honors in German
Allegra Brianna
Wartell Bachelor of Arts in biology and
German departmental honors in German
with the candidates in history please
come forward Samuel Joseph Roberts
Bachelor of Arts in history summa [ __ ]
laude Nicholas Brendon Rowan Bachelor of
Arts history Shadrach Joseph straily
Bachelor of Arts in history magna [ __ ]
laude
Grayson Elizabeth Murray Bachelor of
Arts in history magna [ __ ] laude Daniel :
Ziegler Bachelor of Arts and history and
politics magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in history Ellen Ruth Friesen
Bachelor of Arts in history summa [ __ ]
laude
[Applause]
Dominic Martin Joseph Whalen Bachelor of
Arts in history David Benjamin Woods
Bachelor of Arts history [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Abraham James Paternoster Bachelor of
Arts in history magna [ __ ] laude Juliette
Kathleen as Belle Bachelor of Arts in
art and history magna [ __ ] laude abigail
Jeannette Allen Bachelor of Arts in
history and politics [ __ ] laude rachel
alexandria minovsky Bachelor of Arts in
history [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
rhetoric and public address
[Applause]
David Raymond or Bachelor of Arts in
history and politics magna [ __ ] laude
christopher James Sturgis Bachelor of
Arts in history departmental honors in
history Nathan Bedford klar Bachelor of
Arts in history Kelly and Sullivan
Bachelor of Arts in history
Sabrina Dorian Barlow Bachelor of Arts
in history and politics [ __ ] laude
abigail grace Lawrence Bachelor of Arts
history
Christopher Adam Horne Bachelor of Arts
in history and Greek magna [ __ ] laude
amanda marie Klug Bachelor of Arts in
history summa [ __ ] laude
Abby Louise Titus Bachelor of Arts in
history and politics
[ __ ] laude Emily Kristen Simpers Bachelor
of Arts history Michael Francis Whitman
Bachelor of Arts history
Zachary Paul Van Valkenburg Bachelor of
Arts history
[ __ ] laude benjamin david weeks Bachelor
of Arts in history and political economy
Katie alayan Hillary Bachelor of Arts in
classics and history summa [ __ ] laude
Cameron Charles McGrady Bachelor of Arts
in history magna [ __ ] laude Timothy
Michael palely Bachelor of Arts in
history and philosophy summa [ __ ] laude
David Price chase Bachelor of Science in
history and Exercise Science Eli Andrew
puff Bachelor of Arts in history [ __ ]
laude Kendra Murray Lantis Bachelor of
Arts in history Clara Elizabeth fish
Locke Bachelor of Arts in French and
history [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
French Brooke Christian Sabina Bachelor
of Arts in history and English
[Music]
Adam William Sibley Bachelor of Arts in
history
Mackenzie Lauren self Bachelor of Arts
in art and history with the candidates
in international relations come forward
Elizabeth
Eleanor Clara James Bachelor of Arts in
international relations
[Applause]
would the candidates and international
business and foreign language come
forward shailen valerie Schultz Bachelor
of Arts international business and
foreign language [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Cameron Kirk Maxwell Bachelor of Arts in
international business and foreign
language departmental honors in
international business and foreign
language with the candidates in Latin
please come forward another quick one
marketing and marketing management
Jessica H Wilcox Bachelor of Arts and
marketing management magna [ __ ] laude
McKenna Bednarski Lynch Bachelor of Arts
in marketing management and Spanish
Sophie Murray gareki Bachelor of Arts in
marketing management
Amelia Pearson's culbreth Bachelor of
Arts in marketing management [ __ ] laude
KD T's Eleniak Bachelor of Arts and
marketing management Jacqueline rose
Rafe Bachelor of Arts and marketing
management
[Music]
Joseph Scott thistleton Bachelor of Arts
marketing management Erin Elizabeth cook
Bachelor of Arts marketing management
[ __ ] laude Madeline Elise Bragg Bachelor
of Arts marketing management
Chad Nicolas Schiller Bachelor of Arts
marketing management Christopher Roberts
Paul whittler Bachelor of Arts marketing
management Col Bradley McNeely Bachelor
of Arts marketing management Tanner mark
Sizemore Bachelor of Arts marketing
management Christopher Wagner Ackerman
Bachelor of Arts marketing management
Combe Lauda Christopher David Stewart
Bachelor of Arts marketing management
Philip Austen Hecker Bachelor of Arts
marketing management magna [ __ ] laude
Paige Elizabeth Vanderwall Bachelor of
Arts marketing management Combe Lauda
Caleb Alexander mcnutt's Bachelor of
Arts marketing management summa [ __ ]
laude yeah Andrew Alan's wires Bachelor
of Arts in history and marketing
management with the candidates in
mathematics please come forward
Rose Schweitzer Bachelor of Science and
Mathematics and Spanish summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in mathematics
Abigail Alice petrol bursts Bachelor of
Science in mathematics summa [ __ ] laude
Jaden Lippincott Bachelor of Science in
mathematics
magna [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
mathematics David William Dietz bachelor
of science and economics and mathematics
John Paul Zawadzki
bachelor of science mathematics Jonathan
M Peters Bachelor of Science in applied
mathematics and economics magna [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in mathematics
Thomas Robert Roy sir Bachelor of
Science in mathematics [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in mathematics with
the candidates in music please come
forward
Katherine Therese Howard Bachelor of
Arts music Quintin der le Rikard
Bachelor of Arts in German and music [ __ ]
laude Sidney Murray Orndorff Bachelor of
Arts and Music magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in music Thomas John
ryskamp Bachelor of Arts in accounting
and music summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and music and honors and
accounting
with the candidates in philosophy come
forward Burch Ian McCoy Smith Bachelor
of Arts philosophy Kyle William Hewitt
Bachelor of Arts philosophy
[Music]
Colleen Brady prints Bachelor of Arts in
philosophy and Spanish [ __ ] laude Gretzky
Gil Hamilton West bachelor of science
and mathematics and philosophy summa [ __ ]
laude matthew nicholas Nolan Bachelor of
Science in biology and philosophy magna
[ __ ] laude
Richard rockin Eve flowers Bachelor of
Arts philosophy
Rachel Li's LaSalle Ski Bachelor of Arts
in philosophy and religion magna [ __ ]
laude rebecca k carlson bachelor of
science and philosophy summa [ __ ] laude
at departmental honors in philosophy
[Applause]
what candidates in physical education
come forward physics let's go to physics
Charles J Rose Bachelor of Science
applied mathematics and physics [ __ ]
laude laura Salo
bachelor of science and mathematics and
physics magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and physics
Krystal's yenna coppola bachelor of
science and physics [ __ ] laude would the
graduates and political economy come
forward Tessa
marine our dosa Bachelor of Arts
political economy Audrey Claire Denning
Bachelor of Arts political economy summa
[ __ ] laude Alec Romero Menna
Bachelor of Arts in political economy
magna [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
political economy Alexander Thomas
Miller Bachelor of Arts political
economy magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in political economy dustin James
Bowers Bachelor of Arts political
economy Quinn Elliott Myers Bachelor of
Arts political economy [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in political economy
David Dean groom house the third
bachelor of art of science political
economy and psychology with the
candidates and politics come forward
Ross Michael Hatley Bachelor of Arts
politics
magna [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Adam Dean laughs Bachelor of Arts
politics
Nathan Dillon Cheng Bachelor of Arts in
politics summa [ __ ] laude rachel Leona
Frederic Bachelor of Arts PETA politics
and psychology departmental honors in
psychology summa [ __ ] laude Peter Joseph
Seeley Bachelor of Arts politics Eric
Jeremiah golf Bachelor of Arts politics
James Patrick Burke Bachelor of Arts
politics
Cody Robert mecca's Bachelor of Arts
politics
Samuel James Lucas bachelor of arts
politics [ __ ] laude alexander joseph
Pankau Bachelor of Arts in economics and
politics magna [ __ ] laude garrison Edward
Graz Dale Bachelor of Arts in politics
summa [ __ ] laude Kaelyn Kathleen Michael
off Bachelor of Arts politics
Ryan Kelly Murphy Bachelor of Arts in
politics summa [ __ ] laude Christian
Alexander you Bachelor of Arts in
politics magna [ __ ] laude and the Joe
Chandler Bachelor of Arts in politics
[ __ ] laude taken Riley James Bachelor of
Arts in politics summa [ __ ] laude Kaylee
Danielle McGee Bachelor of Arts in
politics [ __ ] laude with the candidates
in psychology come forward
Daniel James Henrikson Bachelor of Arts
in psychology summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors psychology Emmanuel
Franklin Cecil Boyer the third bachelor
of science and economics and psychology
magna [ __ ] laude
Timothy Adam Irvine bachelor of science
psychology Molly Catherine shooty
bachelor of science and psychology summa
[ __ ] laude departmental honors in
psychology Rebecca
Renee V Cola Bachelor of Science in
psychology [ __ ] laude taylor brittany
Bennett Bachelor of Science in
psychology summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors psychology Lucille and Townley
bachelor of science psychology summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in psychology
Hannah Jean Mogan Berg Bachelor of
Science in psychology [ __ ] laude
Kelsey Anna
Lantis bachelor of science and
psychology kun louder what candidates
and religion come forward
Margaret Lamson Odell Bachelor of Arts
in music and religion Ethan James greven
Bachelor of Arts in religion [ __ ] laude
yeah Yoel patella Bachelor of Arts and
Bachelor of Science in applied
mathematics and religion magna [ __ ] laude
Nathan Brian nephew Bachelor of Arts in
religion magna [ __ ] laude with the
candidates for a degree in rhetoric and
public address come forward Karen Marie
fouché Bachelor of Arts in rhetoric and
public address summa [ __ ] laude Shiloh
Renee Carozza Bachelor of Arts in
rhetoric and public address summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in rhetoric
and public address Jenna Christine Bix
Bachelor of Arts and political economy
and rhetoric and public address
Emily Rae Harville Bachelor of Arts in
rhetoric and public address magna [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in rhetoric
and public address jordan taylor pair
Bachelor of Arts in rhetoric and public
address and sociology and social thought
[ __ ] laude with the candidates for
Spanish come forward
Shelby Lynn bargain cost Bachelor of
Arts in Spanish summa [ __ ] laude with the
candidates for the degree in sports
management come forward Andrew John
Callahan Bachelor of Arts in exercise
science and sports management John
Martin Brennan Bachelor of Science
sports management chance Everett Stewart
Bachelor of Arts sports management Paul
Warren Brock Bachelor of Science sports
management with the candidates for the
degree in sports psychology come forward
hunter McKenzie Stevens Bachelor of Arts
sports psychology Carly Joe Goff
Bachelor of Arts sports psychology
Olivia grace Llewellyn Bachelor of
Science sports psychology [ __ ] laude Ryan
Joseph Rogers Bachelor of Science sports
psychology with the candidates for the
degree in theater come forward
Catherine Elizabeth burrs ma Bachelor of
Arts politics and theater Lane Coburn
Gaudet Bachelor of Arts Theater jessica
Lee McFarlin Bachelor of Science Theater
[Applause]
and I would now ask in conclusion that
the three newly commissioned officers
and the Marines come forward to receive
their respective degrees
[Applause]
Joshua s Bailey Bachelor of Arts and
marketing management magna [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Aubrey Jordan Brown Bachelor of Science
biology Daniel Jeff McAlary Bachelor of
Arts in politics
[Applause]
[Applause]
on behalf of all the faculty I wish the
hardiest congratulations to each and
every graduate we bid you Godspeed
please come back to campus and visit us
again be friends for life dr. Arnn the
granting of the baccalaureate degrees is
complete
[Applause]
William J brought back has been the
chairman of the board of trustees since
2002 he was the chairman of the search
committee that contacted me about this
job and if another had been the one I
probably wouldn't be here whether you're
happy about that or regret it
I don't care he said one of the best
people I ever met and he's retired from
the chairmanship but he will be chairman
emeritus and they'll still live here in
this town and give away free bottles of
wine to anybody who stops by the house
bill brought back please stand up
[Applause]
the new chairman of the board yeah bill
he's a cult figure now their chairman is
Pat Sajak if I'm known some time about
1988 or something I have found out that
he was a man of intelligence and
judgment and Lord knows with hardly able
to be controlled he's a splendid man
he's going to lead the Board of Trustees
and he's going to be great at it Pat
Sajak
thank you very much
it is it is a distinct honor to be here
with all of you a great honor to share
the stage with general Nellore I was
speaking with the general before we came
out here and I said look down I could
only think I really need to shine my
shoes he's I looked positively terrible
next to him I know it's been a long day
and you want to get on with your day and
get on with your life so I will be brief
my comments shouldn't run more than an
hour and a quarter so be comfortable as
dr. iron mentioned I have assumed the
role of chairman of the board here at
Hillsdale a singular honor and privilege
and I'm grateful to the board for
allowing that honor to happen I have
served for the last 15 years as vice
chairman of the board at the right hand
of the aforementioned
Mr broad Beck and when I look at what
has happened on this campus not just the
the physical plant but by any measure
these past years where bill brought back
and and dr. R and have teamed along with
the board have been nothing short of
miraculous and I think when the history
of this institution is written these
will be the golden years of Hillsdale
College and it's been an honor to be
with them as for mr. broad back no one
is more passionate about this place no
one loves this place more no one knows
more about it than this guy and sadly
bill has lost his eyesight but he has
never lost his vision he will continue
to serve on the board and I'm grateful
for that thank you bill
so as for you guys on behalf of the
Board of Trustees congratulations to all
we are so proud of you you should be
proud of yourselves I'm sure you are I
know your family is I know your parents
are your extended family your friends
your neighbors all of those who have
offered some support over the last four
or in some cases five years
congratulations to you all
Hillsdale College is not in the business
of helping to mold merely the next
generation of lawyers and doctors and
businesspeople and teachers we're in the
business of molding the next generation
of citizens and as I look out at this
group of citizens I have great hope for
the future of this country so again go
out there and be good citizens do good
things do great things be happy be
prosperous be successful
keep Hillsdale in your hearts and again
thank you congratulations and God bless
you all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let us pray
may God the Father who brought again
from the dead our Lord Jesus Christ
preserve you and keep you may God the
son who calls his sheep by name and
leads them to green pasture guide you
and save you my god the holy spirit who
gives life to all who call on Jesus by
faith equip you and strengthen you for
every good work and may the blessing of
God Almighty Father Son and Holy Spirit
be among you and remain with you always
amen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]